[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm late you today at the round table of
dim light and we're gonna be talking at
each other and to each other I'm certain
that we'll listen to each other at times
and respond we're gonna go down the
rabbit hole we have no clue and you said
today instead of this week I mean I've
already listening right now I just I
like it when you say this week
on the at the round table of death this
week at the round table of den where you
go rhett and Link you're gonna talk at
each other I just and I just spoke about
us in the third person I don't care what
you say after you say it's as long as
you say this week at the round table of
dim lighting everything is good for me
we have no clue mythical beast where
where this is gonna go because we're
gonna release the rabbit it's gonna go
down hole and the way we release the
rabbit is we open this sealed envelope
it's actually got a piece of scotch tape
but we're gonna open that up and there's
something that is the topic that one of
you submitted what makes it scotch tape
and what about that's a brand name I
know but what makes them and then we're
gonna go
is it scotch down that hole after the
rabbit for as long as it takes to talk
about what we need to talk originally is
what I'm saying don't know is it from
because if something is Scottish that's
from the country of Scotland something
something is Scotch it's it's a drink
well if you're Scotch Irish your Scotch
Irish which I am then you're of those
places you're of the British Isles
so exactly did my people invent clear
tape I'd love to think so like you're
lying no I don't think you got it in
here and I'm sorry civically just my
people as a people so technically
they're your people too because you did
the 23andme thing and you're also from
the British Isles I mean yeah probably
cousins distant distant so if I to do
that but before we do that we're gonna
just quickly let you guys know about
this the impending you've called a
travel
extravaganza at an interesting time for
the past two weeks we have been
basically what I would say on and by on
I mean working you know professionally
participating in our professional
participating profession every single
day for they were probably going on
three weeks now but from either
yeah no no day that's not something
happening making any given day it's
making good mythical morning being at
the Tour of mythicality or traveling to
and fro across the country and I got I
mean I know you're on fumes and I'm on
fumes too man yeah I don't even say the
expression right I'm running on fumes
I'm very in touch with you know we
talked about this how I'm beginning to
be in touch with how my brain is just
now working that great you know I'm very
much in need of this holiday break I'm
super excited about just not having
specific obligations of the professional
variety for a number of weeks so as we
record this I'm you know it's there's a
palpable expectation of relaxation of
just of just letting my brain just just
sit for a second but it's not over
because tomorrow oh no no I it's an
expectation and we're not in it yes
certainly as we record this again and
I'm not trying to gain any sort of
points no no and I'm not complaining
it's just a weird it's just an
interesting time news right boy just to
give her a reality so we we basically
shot the last episode of good mythical
morning for the year mm-hmm today
tomorrow we get on a plane we go to
Orlando Friday we have a show in Orlando
and we fly to Atlanta we have two shows
in Atlanta on Saturday then we fly to
Durham North Carolina we have a show on
Sunday night in North Carolina
homecoming show to wrap up the tour
mythicality but then we don't come back
home no no no
we then fly to New York City from Monday
where we will be on The Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon
so as of the release of this if you're
listening to this fresh tonight we'll be
talking with mr. Fallon and then begin
we then we wake up the next morning get
on a plane again go across the country
back to Los Angeles because the plan was
when we did the Durham show to stay to
stay there because our family would come
with us and then we found out that they
have to be in school until the following
Friday so that plane got busted we have
to fly back we stay quite a few days and
then fly all the way back with the fam
to North Carolina so I'm disappointed
that our family can't be at our
homecoming show I mean they've seen the
show multiple times but you know to be
there with family like we're doing a
pig-picking with family before the ship
will have been fully picked by the time
we eat it yeah they're not bringing a
hot full hog head on hog of course we
could probably request that we could
it's not too late for us but by the time
you're listening to it it's done so you
can't you can't help us out there the
downward spiral into the holidays but
when you go funny how the year just
unravels at the end but in years past
you've gone home like neither of us has
a relaxing time but I do generally stay
in the same place we stay with my
sister-in-law the whole time that we're
there so I'm not I'm going a lot of
places but every night I'm back in the
same place you're typically in multiple
places but isn't that changing this year
I am typically over the course of almost
two weeks in seven different places like
quite literally that's not really I've
become an itinerant person and you want
to give your best to that family I stuff
it especially at the end of the year
you're just like I got nothing they're
like man they went out there to Los
Angeles and became zombies yeah I mean I
think it will you know I'm hoping it's
I'm gonna have a refreshed attitude
towards seeing everybody toward any
people yeah towards towards people
gorgeous you know you get together with
family and there's there's this dynamic
especially now when we only see them in
person
sometimes some of the family members
once a year and this is it you know but
the thing about those family members is
that they're not used to you living in
their space so it's difficult for them
to I mean so it's difficult for
everybody because like we should just
get a hotel and then we could have a
visit experience instead of like we're
setting up shop with three kids but the
thing is your house is that both parties
in it feel it's a lot of adjustment both
parties feel an obligation to stay in
the home because as a visitor you're
like well I feel like I should want to
be here with you and then you're like I
feel like I should want you to be here
with us sure but technically practically
can we practice if you were in a hotel
both parties would be happier but this
is just out of the race no one's work
right we have to do things that make us
unhappy because we're trying to make
each other happy I'm staying in less
place or ironic because my sister-in-law
and my brother-in-law
have a new place that it's bigger and
can accommodate our family so we're
gonna stay there longer but that doesn't
mean we're not staying at my in-laws and
my mama's house and maybe Nana's house I
don't know they live pretty far and then
my my dad's house you know and then he's
got another place at the beach and he's
going down there and it's like well my
god how much am I gonna see before you
go down to the beach you know it oh gosh
it's all this stuff what if it was like
an uncle ring is it uncle Randy and
Christmas vacation is that what Dennis
gonna ask me Randy no ain't Randy Quaid
plays uncle
somebody looked that up I don't know why
I'm not remembering it but he has here's
an RV what if we had RVs that tight
quarters in RV damn with your fam date
in North Carolina immediate family
that's tough no but then you just like
well I'll be on the RV I remember you
know he's always talking about how he's
gonna be out in the RV you know but then
I understand but the one thing that is
different besides staying with my
sister-in-law in her house now is did I
tell you that my dad called and said we
made a decision
then I talked about this on good
mythical more I can't remember we made a
decision this year I just want to let
you know I talked to your aunt TC we're
not giving gifts to each other this year
we made a decision and cousin Eddie is
what Nikki is saying yes cousin Eddie
yeah I I'm not familiar with the movie
I'm familiar with the movie I just
haven't seen the movie you have I'm
sorry Christmas vacation I watched your
family no no seriously that's a it's a
great thing to watch with your family
took their nudity there's usually like
toplessness in those 80s vacation movie
I don't think so I think that's uh I
think that a first vacation vacation
Christie Brinkley's died I don't even
think it's actual nudity
maybe I well that's not shown but it's
implied and it would be very awkward I
mean it's just Anatomy just kids will
get through it fast they'll learn
something but I think you'll get through
it fast
Chris learns Christmas vacation I mean
they sucked on the things when they came
out of the womb I mean what's the
problem with seeing some in a pool I
don't understand but anyway the only
answer that the but Christmas vacation
is is is great you watch it with your
family i watch it with my family I don't
remember anything well I'm ashamed to
say I've been so busy we haven't even
watched the greatest movie of all time
for any time of year in any time of
Earth in the history of movies elf it's
the greatest best movie the greatest
Christmas it's mine it's my favorite
movie of all time
it's mine it wasn't until you started
like Griffin but now that you're Barbara
Barbara Barbara you know he's my number
one if you said that before it's my
number one it's never been my number one
until right it's a great movie I'm tired
of I'm tired of you dog and it's not the
best move I love the movie but to say
it's the best movie of all time it is a
perfect music means you haven't seen
enough movies but you're gonna watch
that you should also do so we're not
buying Christmas gifts for each other
we'll feature but we are still gonna get
them for the kids it's my dad talking oh
that's nice and I and you know cuz
there's like you shouldn't care about
that it's like not for the adults and
it's like yeah cuz I'll get you anyway
oh we're gonna do is
change money imma give you money you're
gonna give me money yeah and I'm like
dad you're a genius and I get off the
phone and I tell Christy I'm like we got
big news we're not getting each other
presents at the Neil Christmas this year
and she's like I am so relieved like I
mean there's so many people that like we
had no clue I mean what am I gonna get
Curt like cousin Curt like I don't know
like another she still get your dad
something but don't get it I mean he's
your dad well I'm his son he's not
getting me anything I think it's a
beautiful thing
I'm gonna give him love and my presence
and he's gonna get in my presence I mean
with us see at your physical presence
and he's there and he's gonna give that
back to me and that's what it's all
right what that is is that's better man
I'm not gonna give him a Lowe's gift
card well he gives me money the problem
is is I've set this precedent with with
my parents like last year we got him
like a like a night at a really nice
bed-and-breakfast and that that's got an
amazing restaurant attached to it and
it's like a night at this restaurant a
night at this bed-and-breakfast and then
this restaurant and you know we kind of
went all out and this like but now you
once you do that you got a key you got
once you dip that deep you got to dip
that deep forever did they go to it they
loved it mmm did they give you details
they called me and texting me while they
were there oh good are you trying to
make it seem you you don't think they
went no it's a place that we knew that
they look at gonna had been we've we
spent our first anniversary there I
think that's great I get I guess I'm a I
you know I don't love getting gifts
because I have this psychological thing
about how much did this cost how much
how much you know I just I get tripped
up with a lot of the gifts and it's just
not my love language so if everyone
agrees yeah I mean if then it's like
here if he initially when you went when
it's like now it's you know you enjoy
seeing the kids open presents but we
just want to be together and catch up we
only see each other once twice a year
now
SOTA like to to relegate that to my dad
trying on a button-up shirt that's way
too big and then saying their shirts way
too big is the receipt in here because
my dad does not pull any punches well
don't you know how I'm getting people
close as always a mistake unless yeah
but as you know that specifically
they're sizing the brand yes we're you
know we're gonna get through this this
this weekend and stuff is gonna be it's
gonna be great wrap up to the tour
mythicality which was a tremendously
positive experience meeting so many
mythical beasts and seeing so many faces
in person we would do the tour we would
do the show then we have a Q&A and it's
a very valuable experience for us to
feel connected but now that we've done
that okay well and I think he's gonna
i'ma go holiday it and also it's the
kind of thing that I think I would feel
differently about I it's been it's been
great while we're in the midst of it but
I would feel differently about it if it
was the only thing that we were doing
for like oh we took a month and we did
this thing yeah I think it's the mixing
of so many different things it makes it
difficult to keep up with but listen
let's transition to the rabbit hole
before that for those of you who have
not agreed with your family members that
you're not going to give gifts to each
other we have the perfect holiday gift
for any for her anyone yes you may think
we're nuts and we are a little bit we
have developed a fragrance mythical
number nine comes in this handy dandy
black and sparkling cologne e perfumey
looking thing is a scent for all people
yes so then women this is children this
is a unisex fragrance that we formulated
with our friends at and we're not riding
a bearded lady so again with everything
that we do with our friends lance and
lacey over at bearded lady we start with
this concept and then we start working
it out and it took us and then we get
everybody involved here so we basically
got all these different scents everybody
with spritz and spray and that's it so
sniffing basically the crew client
collective it was like argh
decided that this is the fragrance that
we all love and I'm really proud of it
I've never worn a scent I didn't know
where to put it
well you put it anywhere you want put it
everywhere except your eyes or your
mouth and your nose does it say that
over there you noted everywhere except
your eyes your mouth and your nose who
did everywhere except in orifice written
that on there there is a note from us on
the back that I'm not gonna read because
I want you to read when you buy it but
it's it's a it's a good amount of
fragrance here it's not so much that you
can't put it in your toiletry bag on the
flight
now I had a guy but it's almost it's the
perfect amount I had a guy I had a dad
come up to me at the tour of mythicality
and he said I want to let you guys know
that your beard oil and your lip balm
good stuff in your pomade it's really
good like it like you did it like yeah
and you know what a couple of youtubers
decide to make products like this yeah
you're like well what kind of you know
they didn't have anything to do with it
but as we've made clear many times we
were intimately involved in the
development of this stuff and they use
only the best materials for this stuff
feel the same exact way about this so
its quality stuff
smell like us yeah well the way we want
to smell not the way we sometimes end up
smelling we can all identify that on
that packaging this is the thing if we
all start wearing this as a mythical
heard then you'll just be able to notice
people just in public but I smell a
mythical beast and you make a new friend
and that was really the reason that we
decided to do this plus it's magic you
know make you smarter did I say that
last part out loud what the magic and
smarter part you know okay you didn't
good I didn't hear it
alright you ready to mythical dot store
mythical dust or you ready to go down
the rabbit hole yeah do it I'm gonna
touch it that you pick it up this is
risky guys so this is a this is a fan
prompt right that's that's where we get
these we get these from the mythical
beasts themselves and then we're just
gonna follow we have a backup if we
think this sucks okay yeah of course
they know that they know us well enough
thank you now this comes from Joshua Wow
Joshua what supposed to mean differently
than the Joshua's that I know Joshua
Tolley what makes something funny
and why do I laugh
at some things than others wow this is
this is pretty interesting were you
involved in this conversation recently
that we were having about this very
thing well I know it one I don't know I
don't think so recently but I I did some
reading on the subject about nine months
ago and I think we talked about that
maybe as an episode of GMM so which
means it could have been two years ago
it runs together but are you saying you
were talking to someone about what makes
something maybe I was there I know I
don't remember though what was the
nature of the conversation I was me Mike
talking about this our friend Mike our
intellectual friend Mike oh yeah and I
don't know how we got started talking
about this but we were talking I wasn't
there specifically what makes something
funny and he talked about how he had
these theories about what makes
something funny but he had once brought
them up in the presence of Pete Holmes
comedian Pete Holmes as a friend of his
and he was like Pete Holmes shot
everything down basically said well this
doesn't apply and this doesn't apply and
I think the the conclusion of that
conversation was that there's not one
thing that makes something funny but
know that but but you can cat it I know
you can categorize the different things
that can make you laugh like the element
of surprise or subversion or you know
people have scientifically analyzed and
categorized these things but it kind of
removes the power of it I mean we can
get into it let's start there because I
I want to just I want to tell you what
Mike told me because I had a theory
right and then his theory kind of
dovetailed into what I was saying okay I
was actually thinking about this in the
context of the tour of mythicality and
how we've been in this group setting
where we've been delivering these jokes
and you immediately know if the thing
that you thought was funny actually was
and we've no right this thing where
different parts of the show are funny
based on where we're at in the country
whether or not people are sitting down
or standing up so some venues
everybody's seated in some venues
everyone's on the floor standing up and
then there's like a balcony list any
variable and it is it is a it is a
viable contributor to whether something
is found funny or not lighting
temperature is a big number you know if
people are general comfort and call it
too cold affectations but one of the
thing I was thinking about like one of
the things that we've we've kind of hung
our hat on just as a comedic device and
we've done this and you see this in so
many of the things that we do hmm is
that that we start in a place that's
relatable like so we bring you in and
get you hooked on something that's
relatable and then we subvert that thing
that's relatable and there's an element
of surprise or subversion that then kind
of makes you laugh and you'll see that
is a pattern that we follow and a lot of
the jokes that we write and a lot of the
concepts that we have in like buddy
system but even good mythical morning
mm-hmm so I was talking with Mike about
this and I said that I feel like there
is something in a laugh that is a non
lingual vocalization of me saying I
relate to this and then if I hear you
laughing at the same thing you're like I
relate to this it kind of goes back to
the whole first chapter of the book of
mythicality
where we kind of we connected and our
senses of humor and it was just like
it's a way to say that like I just
observed something and I have a
vocalization that I can make that is
almost bypasses the the language parts
of my brain which I'm gonna get back to
with Mike's super intellectual analysis
of this in a second because this is
exactly what he said that lets you know
that I kind of get and understand
something and relate to something in a
way that moves me to laughter and then
you can also do that you know so it's
the same and this is one of the reasons
that like you know like when you get
something you get a joke and you kind of
you reach over and you kind of nudge
nudge somebody it laughter is coming
from the same part of the brain and my
in my estimation then this is just one
kind of laughter relational laughter
we'll call that
but Mike I was talking to Mike about
this and he said well interestingly
there's been some research done and this
is and this is also kind of his theory I
don't know how much is his theory and
how much he's read but he was just
telling me about it
but he's a smart dude so it could be a
lot from him but he was talking about
how before humans could actually use
words so there was some point where we
developed the ability to speak but
before that we just were making
vocalizations so you've got your like
caveman grunt sort of situation so you
kind of know like you hungry you observe
chimpanzees and they're gonna be making
these types of vocalizations well he
said there's a situation where and I
wish she was here to explain this but
there's a situation in which you've got
somebody who's walking in the night and
you're walking outside and then another
primate kind of comes up to you and you
surprise each other at the same time and
you instead of you there's no there's
there's no language you have in your not
speaking language but you want to be
able to do something defend to keep
yourself from getting attacked and to
say I'm friendly and so you surprise
somebody inside that is a that is a
completely alarming thing that
immediately you recognize a friend and
not a foe now I didn't do a good job of
explaining that but I've put there some
peace and again that's where it kind of
comes from this relational place so I
think that one aspect of what makes
something funny is you're basically just
saying yes I have that exact perspective
on that thing I totally get this I
remember we we just watch like Sinbad
when he would remember this comedian
Sinbad well yeah and he would be like
doing this like Apollo set or whatever
and I remember he would just tell these
stories about his grandma or his mom
like punishing him and as kids who were
being discipline
by our parents I would watch that and I
would laugh my butt off because I was
also being disciplined by my parents in
ways that were very relatable to what he
was saying uh-huh
and so the way I would kind of just
recognize that is by just laughing my
butt off man hmm
so I think that's one aspect of it that
is just like a it's a defense mechanism
evolution that's the evolutionary
explanation that it comes from a defense
mechanism well that kind of takes some
of the joy out of it well well good luck
with you doing any with digging into
anything scientifically I mean if you
dig into the origins of love
scientifically you're gonna become
disenchanted pretty quickly but that
doesn't mean that it's any less
meaningful it just means that there's a
natural explanation for it it is it is
very meaningful whenever you can without
saying a word at all you can express
like utter agreement like it's it's so
pure because you can't you can fake it
but it's fake like when it's not fake
and you're laughing with somebody like
you said that's that's what solidified
our friendship was that we laughed at
the same things it's that moment where
you know when you really being having an
honest reaction of joy you know it's
like it's a beautiful thing but what
about when you're laughing it's
something that is wrong so what is it
well if someone else is also laughing at
it and it's okay well what worse is it
schadenfreude is that the is that the
word where you're you're laughing at
someone else's misfortune so that's a
different thing right so that but again
there could there's definitely some sort
of deeper explanation that sent it in
our in our genetics but that could be a
situation where there's some adaptive
advantage to the fact that me and you
see some dude do something and we kind
of team up and laugh at him we're
separating ourselves from somebody who
screwed up right which seems like a
horrible thing
but ultimately the reason that you have
a tendency to do that is because there's
some adaptive advantage to sort of
teaming up against somebody who is
falling but you know who's fallen in
some way mm-hmm
but specifically that whole laughing -
somebody's misfortune I'm I kind of go
back to about like the the the the
Community College rant that I that I did
on GMM recently that we've got a really
interesting interesting response to that
right because the vast I hope people
found it funny oh the vast majority of
people were like this was so funny I
loved every minute of it I'm I'm a
community college student I got I got
messages through tweets from a lot of
people basically just saying that like
I'm in Community College and I thought
it was hilarious now I got other people
who said I'm in Community College and I
busted my butt and it's and I am
offended by what you did and I think he
belittled it and what I was trying to
say in the moment was you're making fun
of a stereotype yeah I don't remember
what she said but it's just and nothing
that I said when you think when you
think about my intention nothing that I
said actually disqualifies or undermines
anything that you've accomplished with
the community college education which I
trip which was point was the point I was
trying to make but of course I'm just
trying to be funny when I'm doing that
so I'm even undermining my explanation
in the moment just for the comedy but
what makes that funny right
so and and how much has humor changed
because if I had to made that joke 20
years ago I absolutely no one would be
offended like no one would but like we
know it wasn't a joke I think we live I
think it was totally different first of
all it was like it was it was a shock
joke it was surprising that you you said
something derogatory about community
colleges because you don't expect that
from us on the show and then you were
probably laughing at my reaction at the
same time which supported the fact that
I was also shocked and then the fact
that I was trying to
like smooth it over I hope was found
funny because if people are laughing at
you it supported it supported the
initial reaction of shock and then it
was like yeah I he's he's squirming so
there's like discomfort so that's a
different type of humor they're relating
to you at that the relation and then
there's or it's just I embodied the
discomfort yeah so they relate or they
just find that well which is this the
similar dynamic is again this is
something we go to we go we go to this
well quite a bit where you'll be doing
something that's just ridiculous
you may be gagging on something you may
say something that is unintentionally
sexual or completely crazy in some way
and my responses that's your opinion is
just to kind of look at you like you're
a [ __ ]
or better yet look directly into the
camera like can you believe this guy and
so which I never see that by the way
people my glasses are built people laugh
at what you do initially and then they
laugh at me because I'm trying to
establish a connection with the audience
to be like now I'm now I want you to
relate to me in the way that I perceive
this guy yeah we have this advantage
with that because it's it's too
different if you don't think what I'm
doing is funny then if you act like you
don't think it's funny then they think
it's funny that you're acting that way
so we got double the chances of people
finding something funny even I'm sure
there's people who watch the show who
just it's it goes beyond they got a
favorite so I actually don't find what
linked us funny or what Rhett like Rhett
kind of annoys me because you've fill in
the blank I'm sure oh I'm sure people
feel that way you're not you know we we
try to take full advantage of that you
know it's like and I actually take foil
I take and this is what's wrong with me
is I I take joy knowing that there are
people who are upset about my community
college conversation I think then
they're wrong there were other things
that became funny because first of all
there was the surprise of the fact that
the app the segment derailed like I was
getting so much I loved the fact that
like
it was very clear that none of this was
planned and that we sunk or swim based
on what happened and I think that that's
another you know I don't know if it's as
much funny as this is just a delight
response in there they're off the rails
there you know so there's like a delight
moment and then the fact that you is it
a different reason that it's funny that
you would backtrack and then you would
you step in it again
on purpose that became the bit like
finding that bit was I think funny for
it
for a different reason that it was a it
was a hapless thing I don't know what
they call that when it's like it's more
of a clown it's like if you if you if
you bring that down to its essence at
that moment where you started stepping
in your own poop it was like a clown it
was a it was it was misfortune and it
was a throwback which it's just so Kay
Oh Anna don't you mean a runner yeah but
I mean I kept throwing back to it which
is a runner yeah but the it's so crazy
because but none of this that I think
the beauty of all of it is nobody you
can't define it to understand I you know
it's it's fun to talk about I'm not
making a point we shouldn't talk about
this I am just saying that the beautiful
thing is that it's so instinctual I
think that's where you you enjoyed
talking about the evolutionary origins
of it is that you know it feels like
magic that all of a sudden something
burps out of you because you read you're
reacting honestly to something with
delight like that's a it's just an
amazing moment that like you don't like
the intricacies that we just you know we
just broke down while we thought that
was funny
and it didn't make it funnier well and
we're just and that's the beautiful
thing we're just scratching the surface
and we could be wrong you know well I I
mean but my point is
whether we're right or wrong when you
when you laugh when you smile when you
like that deep belly laugh that happens
that like if you did one of those a day
you would live 10 years longer you're
adding you're adding life to yourself
you know your unless you get hit by a
car fall off the cliff or something well
like you're you know you were creating
longevity with those belly laughs and
it's not something that you can place
yourself in a position do that but you
can't you can't fake it it's just a it's
just an it's just something that happens
at end and that's why comedy should win
Oscars there should be a category is
nothing harder than making somebody
laugh if there is music older comedy it
is a category yeah I don't know there it
no they don't have a Best Actor in a
comedy is that what it is what's the cut
what there's an Oscar thing they don't
have the recognized comedies well they
don't have like funniest actor they
don't have that but they have Best
Musical or Comedy they put it together
with musicals so they well I'll put it
this way then I think that comedy should
be a for Best Picture and they should be
legit
well Hamid II I do think that it's you
know there's different there it's
difficult to do lots of things hard to
scare people but I think is even harder
to make people laugh well okay well
people do it though the way that we
think about like the energy that goes
into making somebody left so I guess I'm
biased because I try to do it well yeah
of course but one of the things that we
talk about with it having done the tour
is like you know once we get out on
stage and people are responding we're
having a great time but there are
moments especially on the show the days
that we do two shows where after the
first show I'm like I kind of rude
rather not do this next show you know if
it was just up to me I would just go to
my hotel room and go to sleep
and we've talked about how if I was just
a musician if that was all we did and it
wasn't funny songs it was just songs
there's a way to kind of get lost in the
music and just kind of just connect with
the music and the people are there
witnessing that but
when you're trying to make people laugh
it's not about your performance it's
about your connection right it's about
your connection to the audience and it
takes a certain amount of energy that I
personally believe is significantly more
than it takes to play music now that
doesn't mean music being a musician is
easy and also we've said many times as
much as people say you guys should write
serious songs and sing serious songs we
know our limitations as musicians and we
think that doing comedic music is a real
sweet spot for us but it is a different
there's a different level of energy
because it's so relational it's so much
about a connection with a with the
recipient of of whatever you're throwing
out there it's just a different it
requires something different do you feel
like it's like a singer/songwriter who
wrote a song about that was like very
poignant and personal to them maybe like
let's say the death of a loved one
getting on stage and performing that
song and just breaking down in tears
every time in order to give that
particular audience to convey the the
depth of the experience of that loss
that they were that they're singing
about in the song like sometimes I do
feel like yeah you know it's we can say
the joke and it'll be funny to get her
laugh but there's other times you can
say like well it's it's weird because
I'm on stage a lot we're both on stage a
lot listening to the other person talk
and I've found that the best one of the
one of the best things I can do is
actually find what you're saying funny
and we haven't talked about this so I'm
curious what you think there's certain
points we're on opposite sides of this
stage sometimes there's a light up on
you and there's not one on me so I'm in
the dark but when I'm and I can tell
that people are still watching my
reaction and if I can find what you're
saying funny as if it's the first time
I've heard it and I'm not actually
acting but there's like that's a hard
place to get back to you when you've
heard a joke 40 times sometimes it
happens and I I do believe it helps the
audience you find it funnier
what are you doing when I'm when I'm
trying to set my mark not-not-not those
opponents it's the beginning of the show
when you're talking and I'm in the dark
I'm looking at one I'm usually looking
at one place in like this with a very
slight smile on my face I don't want to
be a distraction like a statue yeah and
I want to because the original intention
of that portion of the show when we
wrote it was that the other guy would be
completely in the dark and in some
venues we are completely in the dark but
there's other venues where the lighting
is different and it bounces off certain
things and yeah you can basically just
see and there's somebody like three feet
from you and they're like I can look
down there I can see they're looking at
me especially the part where we start
talking about each other yeah all eyes
go to me when you talk about me and vice
versa and in those moments I still I
kind of just picked my smile up a little
bit but but you don't look at me I do
not look at you during those portions of
the show but what about when the I did
when the lights are up and we're next to
each other
yeah I'm just IMing I'm engaged with it
and there's a you know I saw somebody
tweet one of the great things about if
somebody was tweeting about what
happened in Minneapolis or Chicago I
don't know what show it was maybe with
Chicago when you're just sweating you
took the sweater off
yeah and then the sweater became a bit
and I like grabbed you by the sweater
and like led you like a horse well let's
say what happened do we need to all
right no I just seems frustrating to say
you remember the thing with a sweater
but then you don't tell him what
happened well I I think yeah well
basically I mean make it quick I forgot
we start a song and it's her sing along
to a track and I sing first and I
totally blanked on the song like I just
said first time the whole tour that's
happened and it was because I stopped
the song and then before I restarted it
I said well I totally blanked on the
start of the song because I was thinking
about whether I should be wearing this
sweater while singing this song you wore
like your big Mister Rogers sweater you
know it's mr. Rogers singing about like
an R&B song and I just felt weird about
it to the point that I totally blinked
on the lyrics and we discussed this on
stage but you took it off you stopped
the song and then I restarted it when
you restarted the song like
I have this opening thing that I say and
I made it about your sweater and then
and then at the end of that song we have
this thing where we're like facing each
other and whispering to each other on
stage and then you've got the sweater
and I was pushing the sweater away with
my foot and then you were upset with me
this is all obviously just for show but
then I picked it up and I grabbed you I
was upset because you were making my
sweater dirty yeah and I put it around
your neck and like try to make you bow
like I was leading you like a horse and
I saw somebody tweet he was at that show
and they said I don't know the great
thing about this is I just don't know
what part was planned and what was it
yeah so I don't know if the sweater is a
part of every show well it's not and
yeah I'll never wear the sweater again
because it made me forget the lyrics but
if I and I knew we could never recreate
that moment or I would do the sweater
every time but but what you're kind of
not honest about is there's there are
things that are everyone who's there
knows that we're written you know like I
know that they're telling a story that
they knew about ahead of time but then
there's the oh well link just said
something in the middle of read story of
vice versa and now they're riffing on
something well some of those riffs are
things that happened on the third show
of the tour and then we were like oh
what did we say that was really funny
let's make that part of the script and
so now there are riffs that are part of
the script but then every night there's
new riffs that may replace existing
scripted riffs or they may just be added
and so you know like heading into this
final weekend Ford four shows in a row
and also like it's the end of the tour
and it's like we're a little bit looser
we know the material hmm so the ground
is very fertile for just ad-libbing and
riffing on something where we were we're
living for those moments but now it's
this there's this well the first time
link said that thing about so-and-so I
laughed at him and then said this so it
isn't like the next time that I say it
I'm not gonna also laugh at you but now
my laugh has become an act yeah you but
but I thought is that you as the
audience are perceiving the laughs as oh
he's responding to the for the first
time because if I take that laugh out
and now I'm giving you half of the
reality that happened three shows ago I
want you to get the reality that we
created three shows ago so you'll react
the same where the audience did and it
may seem a little less authentic to us
but it feels the same to the audience
well the the the fascinating thing to me
is that like a lot of it is well there's
certain points where we're commenting on
the photos behind us and there's like
subtle things that like the first time
you decided to ad-lib one more joke
about how big your pants were in that
picture I was looking at the audience
and then I had to look back and then if
I just stay there and keep staring at
the photo waiting for you to say the
pants joke it doesn't help but if I turn
back to the audience and then I'm like
okay if I really recreate this as an
honest moment if I put you know if I
reenact it I got to react at the right
moment like oh he's got one more thing
he must have just made that up and
because people pick up on the the most
subtle things and I think that's one of
the things I enjoyed about the show
doing the tour the most is that you
realize the psychology of what makes
something funny it's not just the words
coming out of your mouth it's every
single thing
and you can and the cool thing about it
is you can fine-tune it right
so we sing a song as part of the tour
show that we wrote 15 years ago and I
don't know I I don't wanna I for the
people who well the tour will be over
for the most part well yeah I don't know
when we'll do the show again well I
don't even have to say what that song is
but what we're trying to make a version
that people can walk yeah I don't want
to spoil too and it's a song we wrote a
long time ago and it's really
interesting because we actually talked
about this in the Q&A at one of these
places because there's a difference
between well I think one of the reasons
that we use a song from 15 years ago is
because we wrote that song when we
weren't making YouTube videos but we
were if we were doing a funny song it
was in front of us a crowd and so we
wrote songs that made sense in like a
live setting but then once YouTube came
along and we started writing songs we
were thinking just as much about the
visual that was gonna accompany that as
we were the lyric and so now we've got a
lot of songs that sure they may be funny
to listen to but they're intended to be
very funny when you watched
music video but if we were to just break
those songs out and sing them live you
kind of be like I don't in fact the one
song that really is is like that we in
the show we show the music video as we
sing it right whereas the rest of the
songs or songs that pretty much exist
for an audience to just enjoy so there's
just this this dynamic well this it's a
different type of comedy I mean it there
it's like to get a laugh on a stage in a
song is different than to get a laugh in
a YouTube video when you have the visual
component and we started writing towards
that and I think that's why we that's
why again why I enjoy the live show so
much is that it's a different it's a
different way to be funny I mean it's
everything is scripted I mean which is
in stark contrast to good mythical
morning you know and so it was
energizing for us from a from a comedy
standpoint to say okay how do you make
somebody laugh in person that's not what
we've been doing I mean there are points
when we just we just couldn't give it we
didn't want to do a good mythical
morning live we could certainly do that
later and it yeah it you would find it
funny and it would be recreating the
screen experience in real life but I
mean from a from a creative standpoint
that wasn't as exciting to us because it
was it would have been the same thing
well go I mean right now I don't think
we'd be happy to go out for this long
weekend and do it one more time if we
were gonna sit behind a desk and do this
thing but I mean it's well it kind of
goes back to what you just said when
you're talking about the the person who
sings like a heartfelt song so let's say
there's somebody who has this very
moving song about somebody dying and
they cry when they when they perform it
and then you go to the concert and you
see them do this and you see them cry
and you like no well they they can't cry
every this is now this is a performance
right seeing somebody cry even if
they're legitimately great at it and
they're there's tears flowing and
everything and they're able to conjure
up some kind of emotion if you saw that
every
that's a much different sensation than
seeing somebody laughs and knowing that
they probably laugh at this point every
single day like that's it much easier
pill to swallow see somebody fake humor
than fake actual sorrow right that's we
don't we don't tolerate that as a
species someone who is entertaining us
and I actually knew a guy like this who
had this way of speaking when he was
getting very serious about something and
he started to sound like he was crying
right but he wasn't crying was this what
do we do yeah but it was a I just wanna
say one more thing yes in it but it
wasn't that fake it wasn't as fake as
you're going but it was this tinge of
I'm very sad right now but I knew that
he was just saying something to me that
he had said to other people before and
mmm I had this really negative reaction
to it
well yes anyway that I don't feel one
thing to be on a stage it's another when
you it's like okay this is a mode but
you do that interpersonally but there
are that there are comedians who laugh
at themselves I mean we we do that quite
often I just did it a little bit right
there but when you when people you laugh
when people was that fake is that what
you say no what's it I mean this is fake
right now I mean yeah this is fake I
can't decide if what I just did was fake
really that's how far we've come I had
an emotional reaction a positive
reaction of what you did until it dawned
on me it was fake but my by my knee-jerk
reaction was I felt good for one little
second and then I felt really bad cuz I
determined it was fake but if you take
something like a funny Broadway show
right so as far as I know unless
somebody's phone rings Broadway shows
don't have a lot of improv you know what
I'm saying like if that's not what
you're there for mm-hmm they do the same
show every single night 99% identical
unless they screw up comedians feed off
the crowd they do a different thing
somebody says something somebody heckles
they get in on that and they dig in on
that they may change things up but when
you've paid to see a Broadway show you
want to see
the Broadway show that you paid to see
those people are doing and they say it's
like Book of Mormon or whatever so it's
a funny show
those people are doing the same thing
night in night out you know six seven
nights a week May I don't know how many
nights a month sometimes for some of
these people and they're trying to
capture that performance I've thought a
little bit about what that might be like
having just done like a few shows in a
row mm-hmm
and I think that those people might be
able to retreat a little bit into the
performance and they know it so well
that they may be up there performing I
think you can pick it out and they're
thinking about I've got to pay the bills
when I if you have a decent seat I think
you you will experience a difference not
if somebody's great not if somebody's a
great performer I don't think you pick
it up well I think all you really mean
is that if you're if they gave the
performance of a lifetime you'll be
blown away but just their baseline
phoning it in
if they're great is still gonna be great
but it's not their greatest the
perception of I think I think ultimately
what this comes back to is the
perception of authenticity is a very
important part of humor well I'm also
interested I'm certain that it's not I'm
certainly there are musicians that are
like oh it's the same for me it's the
same for us musicians and I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna disagree with that but I
watched enough of American Idol and The
Voice coaches about how you gotta
believe the word yeah but I but we've
also been in a band though I mean it
wasn't anything like what we have now
but I there was a time when her love
will you believed it it's still a sucked
but B it was what was a better
performance is like well it sucks but I
can tell he's he believes in what he's
what's doing but the music is the thing
that sometimes energizes you even if I'm
because we obviously we played for the
smallest of small crowds we would go to
some places and there'd be seven people
there that stuff it's tough but then
where do you find the energy you find
the inner closure and I amuse it close
my eyes you find it in the music but I
wouldn't just for its fisheye but it's
be like but can you do that what comedy
can you go to a comedy club and have
those seven people who aren't laughing
at all and get up there No
it's gonna be awkward and you're gonna
the air is gonna be taken out of your
performance I mean way that you can get
lost in the music you can't do that what
comedy I mean I'm thinking about born
standing up the Steve Martin book book
autobiographies autobiography yeah that
um I mean you mentioned in a Q&A a
couple weeks back yeah one of my
favorite books maybe I want to reread
that I recommend that you read that if
you haven't if you're interested in this
type of stuff because that gets inside
of his his life his psyche but I
particularly remember like his what was
going through his brain when he was on
stage and how you know you got this one
joke and it all comes down to this one
moment and if somebody sneezes at the
wrong time in the very back like the
bartender in the very back of the venue
it's such a fragile little sneeze and
it's like it's thrown off and you're
like okay I got to let that one go and
it's exhilarating when you're like your
brain is firing you're so on and then
it's like okay I want something to go
wrong so I can prove that this is not
something that this is something that's
just popping off the top of my but you
want it to go wrong at the right place
because one of the things yeah but but
you wanted to yeah yeah yeah I kind of
switched tracks there in the middle you
want it to be it's such a fragile thing
it took for it to work the way you've
well and you want something I'm so good
at it when you've planned it and then
when it that's a whole other level that
you can but you want something to go
wrong because it's just because of you
in a lot of ways I mean yeah sure
sometimes somebody says something in the
crowd and you make a moment out of it
but I think that that's one of the
that's one of the things that just as a
as a performer is frustrating when
there's you know and they'll be we've
got these moments in the show where the
whole point is that it's there's nothing
happening here and sometimes there's
like a the lights go out and we're
moving to a new position and you know in
an ideal world if everybody if the stage
hands knew what was going on which
incidentally the stage hands for our
shows it's always a new crew it's the
house crew so they have to be taught
what all the beats are and sometimes
they're good and sometimes they're not
but if something kind of screws up and
all of a sudden there's seven new
seconds in this blackout that you never
expected
well the crowds natural response at a
show like ours is for somebody to yell
out something and depending on what they
yell out is if they yell out something
in the lights come up less than two
seconds after they yell something the
expectation is well rhettandlink you're
gonna say something about that rattling
you're gonna respond to that and then
there's this choice then we have to make
in the moment am I gonna respond to the
thing the person said or am I gonna say
the thing that I know I'm supposed to
say right now but if they say something
in the guy's back down in like four to
six seconds have passed then the moments
gone and you just say that it's so it's
such a fragile thing and like you said
if you begin to talk and then they say
like if you're beginning to talk as the
lights come up in that's when somebody
decides to say something you know it's
part it's it's part of being a comedian
in our crowds are generally like super
respectful and they're not trying to
make the moment about them mm-hmm but I
can only imagine what it would be like
to be like a stand-up comedian I have so
much I mean I have a I have such a ho
don't know you renewed and heightened
appreciation for what it what it means
to be a good stand-up comic having done
what we do I mean that's an aspect of
what we're doing I would not call a
stand-up comedians by any stretch of the
imagination but we're in that there are
we're in that mode a few times and for
the for the people that are great at it
it's like oh that's I mean that's what
it says heart is anything that's any
occupation is difficult to do and to
nail it
it's it's a yeah I got a lot of respect
for those people that done and you know
this you you see this a lot where
there's somebody who is really funny in
a crowd they tend to say funny things at
the right time they seem to have good
timing and they're kind of life of the
party and then people like you should be
a stand-up comedian and what you'll find
more often than not is that someone
who's actually a good comedian good
stand-up comedian you meet them in
person you'd be like
what's what's what's special about this
person this person doesn't talk a lot
the person seen what's eating that
person actually thinking a lot right now
this person seems to be super
introspective what what what that dude
is such a downer watch out for that
person because they're gonna be that's
where your stand-up comedians gonna be
because there's somebody who's observing
and internalizing the things it doesn't
mean that there's not these
life-of-the-party you know you throw I
don't know we you know we met Kevin Hart
in person and he was on when the camera
was on and he was on when the camera was
off mm-hmm we like rode across town with
him just the three of us in a car and it
was like he first of all he was super
nice and like all business when we were
just talking yeah he wasn't honey he
wasn't trying to be funny at those times
yeah no one laughed but he can turn it
on super easy but I think that I'd say
the majority of people you just meet
somebody and they just seem like a
thoughtful person
it doesn't always it is the person who
cannot who's great in a crowd and super
extroverted and always says the right
thing when you say hey go put together a
stand-up set it doesn't follow that
they're gonna be able to create
something from thin air and then take it
in front of a crowd it's just a totally
different it's coming from a totally
different place I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to do it I wouldn't want I we have
all these crutches that we can hold on
to but we go to a place and you know
everyone there except for the very few
people who've been dragged there by
relatives know who we are like what we
do and know why they think we're funny
so we've won the battle before we start
the show oh yeah and then we're doing
things like well this scripted part here
and this song here that's gonna be a
crowd pleaser but just to stand up there
raw and I think this is one of the
reasons that traditionally stand-up
comics don't really respect musical
comedians like oh that guy with a guitar
because it's like it's a crutch it's
it's a barrier it's a wall you stand
behind it's a way to protect yourself
from the audience but you take that
guitar down and all you have as a
microphone now it's you and your mind
being exposed to a crowd of people and
you have to be able to translate what's
in your mind in a way that makes
makes them laugh and as we've already
established there's something scientific
going on but it's very complex
yeah and it's I mean it's I'm glad we
talked about this because it gave me a
renewed appreciation for the experience
we've had on the tour that you sit down
and we write out and plan out what we're
gonna do on stage in order to get laughs
and then now at the end of the tour we
see how much it's changed because we
weren't right about everything and we
fixed we had to fix it you know and I
still got to fix that like deceased
grandma joke about Christy's grandma
like cuz you can't say that can't say I
cannot say that one in front of I mean
it's kind of an anti joke anyway it's a
joke intended to get a reaction that's
not a laugh it's it's in order to set up
for the next joke right we'll do that
but you can't say any but now I can't I
can't talk about how her grandma was
deceased because her Kristi's parents
gonna be in the audience so we're gonna
I'm gonna lose that set up but I still
got it what they will cedeño Joe so then
the thing that I have to say after I
still got to say I got to move on so
it's just gonna I'm gonna feel a little
defeated inside but I think that I can
take one for the team and I you know I
went out all directions with that thing
and I never I it bothers me that I
didn't land on something new I have I
just came up with the joke I just came
up with the joke I think I'm can I pitch
it to you right now yeah I think your
new joke should be what should I say
what the joke is I don't want to leave
him out of this well yeah so I tell the
story about how I emailed Jesse's
grandmother as a conduit to then have
her print the email out and then mail it
to her the story from the book if you've
read the oil from the book and then so
they're not talking about how that was
awkward and whatever and then link says
I say well when Christy and I first
started dating communication was
difficult for us too because her grandma
I didn't have an email address she was
deceased and it still makes me laugh the
whole of that cottage know
all crowd just is like God but a few
people laugh at her grandma didn't have
any mail address yeah it's not I wish
that was a better joke so here's my
pitch let me just throw this and then I
say but that's the setup
which is yes right because then
everyone's like ooh it feels really bad
and then I'm like I don't know if you
know this about me but I have a talent
for making things awkward
and then everybody laughs because a
everybody there knows me and knows that
that's true about me and it be I just
did and it breaks it breaks it breaks it
attention breaks the tension which is
another way to be funny but what if you
said by the way her grandma was deceased
and by the way we all do that we all
deceased yes now and sometimes I've said
that to the audience what it wasn't what
about this what if you say and I'm not
saying that this is comedy gold but I
think it's a step in the right direction
and it's appropriate for her the crowd
when the grandma and when the your
in-laws were there if you say
communication was difficult for me and
Christy as well I didn't know her
grandma's email address I'll try it
that's better
the only thing is having done it so much
I got like a muscle memory oh no no no
no I'm gonna be so fixated on saying
that right that I'm gonna screw it up I
got a practice in the shower a lot no
you know what I'll do it I'll have to do
it on on the the Atlanta shows I think I
gotta try that it isn't like the joke
has been so great that oh and you know
ahead of time and if it works I can
still do this she was an plus she was
deceased like if if I screw that up and
don't get a laugh I can still say the
deceased one in Atlanta and I I'll have
I have three times to practice it yeah
and you can see what kind of laugh you
get on the front end what was it because
because I didn't know her grandma's
email address now the question it's a
dry joke it's like and it and it is a
little off what if you wet it up a
little bit what if you say what if I was
because you say for the life of me I
could I didn't know her grandma's email
address that's a you joke not a me joke
my joke will be say that but then do
something weird with my head
you know it's like like that thing I
started doing well you do that in us you
do that shortly after I write I do yeah
do that you can't do that there and then
when you do this thing with the head
then it becomes annoying you can only do
that like two times a show you know so I
learned I learned that you know Rhett
will pitch me jokes like that and then
I'm like yeah that would be a great joke
for you
but it's like a chicken neck in it I got
a better one communication was also
difficult for me and Christy when we
were getting into each other because I
didn't know Gaga's email address you
still like you want to your grandma you
wanted to use my same grandma because
Gaga refused to send a mutton because
Gaga refused to print my emails out from
this is getting better see we're getting
better yeah you say you're finally
decided to help communication with me
and Christy was difficult in the early
stages of our relationship - because
Gaga refused to send my emails to
Christy to print out my emails for
Christy that's it that's the joke I
guarantee you that I'll get last now why
is that funny
I don't know because I came up with it
why was that funny because it was not
true
[Laughter]
this is beautiful I'm glad you were here
for this guy's I think Joshua we have
not really answered your question but it
was an inspiring start to a fun
conversation which allowed us to thank
you you allowed us to appreciate what we
what we did through what would you allow
us to depreciate ourselves anytime we
can do that there's no better you know
that's not what I was trying to say I
think in a moment when we rut early
exhausted I and I'm gonna be done with
the tour I now feel motivated to do it
these last four four more times and the
best ever in the high points gonna be
that joke that I just came up for you
came up with for you you're gonna need
to write it down you know what can you
get Gaga to write it down
she'll be there on Sunday when you write
it down and mail it to she can mail it
to me see it's not working that great
okay all right guys I know we're at the
end of this thing but and we meant to
say this at the top but we are taking a
break for the next few weeks from
recording an ear biscuit the next ear
biscuit will be delivered fresh to you
on January 15 yeah in the new year we'll
have we'll have lots to catch up on and
we will we will we will fold you in like
like like the biscuit batter in the bowl
just fold it and fold it and then we'll
bake it and January 15th that thing will
come out so sit tight we got lots of old
Eeyore biscuit so you can listen back
through there don't they don't get stale
they don't not get stale or can some of
them have a cheese surprise in the
middle really I didn't tell you okay
I've been putting cheese surprises in
the minute listen to every one and see
which one has cheese in it
[Music]